hi I'm International Master Danny wrench
Chief chess officer at chess.com
this is an ancient board game it dates
back as far as 600 A.D and is played on
a 64 square board rotating between 32
dark and 32 light squares
you're going to learn how each piece
moves that the goal of the game is to
Checkmate the enemy King
how to set up a chessboard and more
let's jump in
when I teach chess I like to start with
the easiest pieces to understand first
moving our way toward the more
complicated movements let's start with
the Rook
each player has two Rooks and they start
in the corners of the board
a rook is often called a castle by
beginner chess players but the true and
proper name is a rook
Rooks are the second most powerful
pieces on the board and their movement
is extremely simple to understand they
can go up and down or side to side
in any One Direction as far as they
desire
the next easiest piece to understand is
the bishop
each player also begins with two Bishops
just like the Rooks but unlike the Rooks
we forever will have a light square and
a dark Square Bishop
Bishops are stuck to their respective
starting diagonal for the rest of the
game
they can move along these diagonals as
far as they want in any One Direction
one move at a time
however they are never allowed to cross
over to the other diagonal
chess players often refer to the board
as having a dark squared bishop or a
light squared Bishop
the next piece to learn is the queen
Her Majesty is by far the most powerful
piece on the chessboard
she combines the powers of a brook and a
bishop together
that means from a square like this she
might at one point move like a rook
as far as she wants on the straight
lines of the board or in this case like
a light Square Bishop reaching as far as
she wants to the furthest corners and
diagonals of the chessboard
she can move as far as her heart desires
as long as she doesn't run into another
piece and maintains the movements of a
rook or a bishop
now it's time to learn about the Knight
because of its equine appearance a
knight is often referred to as a horse
by beginner chess players but as a true
chess player after watching this video
you will now refer to this Noble Steed
by its proper name the Knight
a knight moves like a capital l
in any One Direction
two squares forward and one square to
the side
depending on the direction that it
starts to it stays moving two squares
within that direction before completing
the movement as we can see like a
capital l
to find its final Square
a knight is also the only piece that can
hop over another piece on the way to its
final destination
in this example we have a black pawn
taking away the knights route to the
square B6 or B4
however the Knight is not actually
prevented from going to the square it
hops right over the enemy piece
often beginner players assume that
because they hopped through this piece
to their final square that they can take
this piece off the board that is not the
case
the Knight is seen as bypassing any
pieces on its route to its final Square
you would however capture an enemy piece
if that piece were on the final Square
you're moving to
now it's time for us to talk about the
little guys
the pawns may seem like the lowliest and
shortest of your pieces but they are
actually the ones with the most
potential and also the most numerous
each player starts out with eight pawns
respectively along the second rank for
white
eight pawns respectively along the
seventh rank for black
a pawn can only move forward one square
at a time and never can a pawn move
backward
however
what we'll learn about the pawn
is that there are more exceptions to the
movements of how to play with a pawn
than all of the other pieces combined
for starters
on the first move only pawns have the
option to move two squares forward
instead of just one
now this is not an obligation if one
player chooses to move a pawn forward
two squares that does not mean the other
player has to
you can choose at any time to move
forward one or two squares but again
upon only has the option to go two
squares on its first move from then on
out a pawn is stuck moving one square at
a time
foreign
speaking of exceptions of how to move
the pawn
s are the only pieces that capture
differently than they move
here we have two pawns directly opposing
each other along the E file
these two pawns are not able to capture
each other should they reach a deadlock
in the middle of the board
pawns only capture diagonally also only
one square in front of them
a pawn cannot capture upon directly in
front of it
foreign
the special rules we have about our
pawns continue
pollens have a unique goal that no other
piece has
if it reaches the other side of the
board upon is the ability to promote
itself to any of the other pieces
besides a second king
this is referred to as Pawn promotion
because a pawn does not have the ability
to move backwards
if he completes the long journey
the pawn can replace itself with a new
Queen
or a second Queen if you still have one
a rook
a bishop
or a knight
often the end of the game is set up for
the pawns to race each other to see who
has the ability to get a new Queen the
most common piece chosen first
our final rule about the very
complicated pieces known as the pawns is
called on poisson
pawns have a very special move and it's
a move that many even practice chess
players still confuse
the rule works like this
if one of the pawns has reached either
the fifth rank for white
or the fourth rank for black this Pawn
is impinging on the other pawns who may
try to move two squares directly by the
pawn in front of it
because this was not always the case
long ago pawns were not allowed to move
two squares on their first move and were
required to go one square thus allowing
a potential capture
when this rule changed allowing pawns if
they choose to move two squares directly
by a pawn
the rule was also added on poisson which
is French for in passing
in this position if white tried to go
two squares with a pawn right beside
this Pawn on the fourth rank black would
have the option not the obligation to
capture this Pawn on passant
this move only works because the pawn
tried to move two squares directly by
the pawn
if this Pawn had moved one square
and white chose another random move that
turn we'll make one for an example
and only then move to this Square you
would no longer have the ability to
capture on passant
the rule was only invented to prevent
moving two squares directly by a pawn
who has worked so hard to reach the
fifth or the fourth rank respectively
I have a fun rule I like to say to help
my students remember this if the pawns
have ever faced off
that means you have to keep your hands
off
so the fact that they had the ability to
capture each other but chose not to
means that there is no longer the
ability to amp assign again it only
works if a pawn tries to move two
squares by a pawn that has been
patiently waiting on the fifth or fourth
rank
you did it we've made it all the way to
learning how the king moves
kings are also complicated because the
Checkmate in enemy King is to win the
game
but before we get to that
learning how the king moves is actually
very easy
the king moves one square at a time in
any direction it wants
Kings can only go one square but they
are actually the only other piece
besides the queen that protects and
attacks every Square physically next to
the current square that it stands on
the one trick about that is that kings
are not allowed to go to a square if it
is currently attacked by an enemy piece
here's an example where the Rook
controls the entire e-file
so this King while it can still go to D4
C4 C5 C6 and D6 the king cannot access
E4 E5 or E6 at this moment as that would
put the king in check
what is check I'm glad you asked
check in chess
is when a king has come under attack by
an enemy piece
and this position the White Queen has
several ways to put the black king in
check
she can move like a rook up to the sixth
rank placing a direct attack on the king
likewise she could move like a rook to
the first rank delivering an attack
along the f-file
moving like a rook to B2 would also be
delivering a check if you consider the
Queen's Movement Like a bishop along the
dark Square diagonal
respectively A1
as well as the squares F5 and G6 would
all be moves that the queen could do to
attack the enemy King in this position
when the king is in check you should
look for three ways to get out of it
now that we've added the black Rook
if the White Queen were to move to the
B2 Square black would actually have all
three of these options at his disposal
the first way to get out of check and
often the most common one should look
for is can I capture the enemy piece
that is attacking my king
in this position black could actually
move the Rook from E2 to B2 and capture
the piece that is attacking his leader
often the second option you should look
for when your king is under attack is if
you can block the piece that's checking
your king
in this case The Rook could also move
backward to the square E5 which by
interposing the diagonal between the
queen and the King
The Rook has blocked the check to the
King on F6
the third option to get out of check is
simply to move the king to safety black
could move the king to F5 G5 G6 F7 E7 or
E6 to get out of check here
note that neither G7
still in check
nor E5 get out of check
those two squares would not be legal for
the king to find safety
it's time to learn how a chess game is
won
Checkmate is when a king is under Fire
just as I showed in the last example but
none of the three options to capture
block or run away is available to the
King this is called Checkmate and it
ends the game immediately
in this position black actually has
several ways to deliver Checkmate to the
white king
the first and most common is what we
refer to as a helper mate
the queen has placed herself directly in
front of the white king
this King clearly cannot find safety on
either of these two squares as they are
attacked by the enemy Queen
but because this King helps the Queen
the white king is also not allowed to
capture as we learned earlier you can
never place your king under check by an
enemy piece even if that peace is the
enemy King himself
this is one example of a helper
checkmate
the other example is on the Square G2
just like before the king is attacked
and he's trapped with no ability to find
safety no ability to capture and
obviously no peace to block to protect
three other examples of Checkmate in
this position
are queen to C1 where just like a rook
the queen is delivering a check and this
king is unable to find safety on either
of these squares as they are both
controlled and protected by the black
king
both B1 and A1 deliver Checkmate in
similar fashion
a very common source of confusion for
beginner chess players is the difference
between checkmate
and stalemate
the difference between these two
positions is that in the previous one
the king is under attack directly
opposed by the enemy black queen
in this position while it is also one
that white cannot find safety with any
king move as every one of those squares
is under attack by black it is not
indeed Checkmate because the king is not
currently being attacked by an enemy
black piece
beginner players often make this mistake
remembering that a key part to Checkmate
is indeed to trap the enemy King however
you must also be attacking this King in
order for it to be Checkmate not just
trapping him to where he has no legal
moves
Checkmate wins the game for black in
this position where his stalemate is a
draw meaning a half a point in the
scorings for each player
you're almost there we're this close to
you playing your first chess game just
after we learn how to set up the board
but before we do that we have to learn
about one more special move it's the
only move where you can move two pieces
in one turn
let's talk about castling
in the position you see before you both
white and black have their kings on what
you'll learn is their starting position
along with each player possessing one
rook in the corner
to illustrate the two different ways to
Castle one to the short side of the
board meaning only two squares between
the king and Rook
and for black to the long side of the
board we have three squares between the
king and the Rook we've set up both
white and black with different starting
positions
to Castle for white
moving two squares to G1 followed by The
Rook hopping over to the F1 square is
what a completed Castle position looks
like
for the short side of the board for
white
moving to the long side of the board for
black the king would move to C8 and The
Rook would land on the d8 square
castling as said is the only move where
you can move two pieces at once and you
can only castle if both of those pieces
have not yet moved at all from their
original squares
two final notes about castling before we
set up the board and let you play
if a king is in check he is not allowed
to run to safety via castling
white would first have to deal with this
bishop checking the king assuming there
were other pieces on the board to do so
otherwise he would have to move the king
or block the check and either way may
lose his right to Castle because the
king would have to move away from its
original Square
similarly we look across to this side of
the board where even though the black
king is not currently in check in order
to pass to the C8 Square you would have
to cross over the d8 square which is
currently under the eyes of the gazing
Bishop on G5
just as I said black would have to have
other pieces on the board to block that
bishop or in this case try to block the
diagonal but either way would likely
lose the right to castling if such a
trade occurred as the moment the King
has moved and is no longer on its
original Square you have lost the right
to Castle
we made it it's time to set up the
chessboard and get you playing
before we add any pieces however take a
good look at the board orientation
you'll note that both black and white
start out with white squares on the
right
for white this is always H1 for black
this is always A8
raise your right hand and make sure a
white square is on the right before you
start adding any pieces to the board
next we like to use the term tallest to
smallest adding both the kings and
queens respectively for each Army in the
center of the board
you'll note that the White Queen starts
out on a white square
with the black queen starting out on a
black Square this should always be the
case with the Kings starting out on the
opposite color squares of their
respective Army
next
I like to add The Bishop's next to the
Royal Family
keeping with the tallest to smallest
approach your Bishops will almost always
be the tallest pieces after the royal
couple
now we add our Noble steeds the knights
start out respectively on G1 and B1 for
white
and G8 and B8 for black
finally we add the towers of power the
Rooks fill out the corners
making sure we will have the ability to
castle with our King and Rook as we just
learned
finally it's time for us to add the
little guys as we've learned the pawns
are little in stature But Mighty and
potential and if a pawn reaches the
other side of the board promoting it
will be a happy day for any chess player
who manages to complete that long
journey
taking a good look one more time you see
the pieces on the first and eighth ranks
respectively
with the pawns filling out the second
and seventh ranks for each player
you did it we've set up the entire chess
board you learned how the pieces move as
well as all the other special rules that
make the game of Kings so much fun
head over to chess.com and make your
free account today to get playing and
please hit subscribe before you go
anywhere else here on YouTube we'll see
you around on chess.com
foreign
[Music]